hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich habe heute ein super leckeres
und einfaches er für euch welches ihr
auch gut vorbereiten könnt es gibt
nämlich heute ein etwas zitrone des
panna cotta mit himbeer auflage murat
findet dass dieses rezept auch so
bislang so ein flug oder erinnert wobei
dieser kein joghurt ist sondern er so
ein charakter mit zitrus eben und ich
zeige euch jetzt einfach mal ganz gut
zutaten also ich hab hier 200 g
schlagsahne 200 milliliter milch 100
gramm zucker eine bio zitrone davon
poppig saft in schale
ich habe hier mein vanille extrakt ein
becher schwanz denn auch 200 gramm und
fünf gramm magazine und später für die
frucht auflage brauche ich 250 gramm
beeren sind jetzt frische ihr könnt aber
auch tiefgekühlte nehmen
ein esslöffel zucker noch mal bio
zitrone und da brauche ich auch malaga
tine und zwar ein viertel teelöffel und
magazine nehme ich immer ganz gerne wenn
ich etwas auf kochen muss also wenn man
jetzt beispielsweise etwas mit gelatine
finden muss nämlich immer stattdessen
magazine weil es einfach die pflanzliche
variante ist und ja vorbereitung geht
auch ganz schnell deswegen fangen wir
direkt an ich gebe jetzt zuerst die
sahne hier in den topf
daran kommt im minus mit dazu der zucker
und ich schreibe jetzt auch direkt die
zitronenschale mitreißt die bringt jetzt
auch richtig diese frische mit rein
normalerweise ist panna cotta ja eher
auf vanille basis also schmeckt
eigentlich nur nach vanille
aber ich finde jetzt zum sommer muss auf
jeden fall mit früchten machen
schmeckt einfach viel frischer und etwas
leichter wobei es nicht leicht fester
da nehme ich auch direktes vanille
extrakt davon gebe ich jetzt auch einen
guten schluck mitreisenden nach vanille
sonst auch schmecken
ihr könnt natürlich auch vanillezucker
nehmen aber da habt ihr einfach diesen
intensiven geschmack nicht denn in den
vanille exakt steckt ja echt aber nie
damit drin und dem vanillin zucker
steckt zum beispiel nur künstliche
vanille und ja deswegen nicht das ganz
normal und auch die akademie mit reihe
alles noch nicht auf kochen erstmal
verrührt
wenn sich das alles verbunden hat lasse
aufkochen und dann muss diese mischung
zwei minuten lang kochen damit die
akademie ihre wirkung entfalten kann und
es dann eben später auch bindet
und nachdem zwei minuten nämlich zum
herunter im übrigen star aufpassen dass
es nicht überkocht also ich hab dann die
hitze auf mittlerer stufe gestellt und
immer wieder gerührt damit eben nicht
überkocht und jetzt nehme ich hier mein
sport management gibt den in glas und
hat ihm schüssel
ich mache jetzt in dem glas damit ihr
sehen könnt und am besten auch etwas mit
seinem aus bild richter dann könnte es
nämlich später gut funktionieren
das frühere ich jetzt ganz kurz
und ließ dann auch direkt diese heiße
masse mit
dann gut durchführen damit diese
klümpchen weg gehen und sich alles schön
verbindet
und zum portionieren nehme ich jetzt
hier diese kleinen beck gläser passen
140 milliliter rein und sehr mal diesen
süßen deckel und da kann ich sehr schön
verschließen
und es sieht super hübsch aus aber ihr
könnt auch ganz normale kleine
trinkgläser benutzen oder dessert
schälchen und wenn er keine 8 kleine
mini portionen haben wollt nehmt ihr
einfach für große gläser oder macht die
doppelte menge für acht große gläser und
jetzt kann ich hier mit diesem behälter
des ganzen freien gießen
und jetzt stelle ich dies so erstmal in
den kühlschrank damit sie fest werden
können so für etwa eine halbe stunde bis
stunde dann fängt das ganze auch schon
an zu studieren und danach mache ich
dann erst diese himbeer frucht einlage
oder dieser auflage gibt da oben drauf
meinte selbst noch im kühlschrank also
seit etwa einer halben stunde und ich
werde schon mal die himbeeren pürieren
und aufkochen damit jetzt auch gleich
etwas abkühlen können
also ich gewiss die himbeeren direkt in
den kleinen topf hab ich vorher auch
direkt gewaschen dann nehme ich die
zitrone
da habt ihr die schale schon fürs der
serbe nutzt um jetzt brauche ich nur den
saft
würde ich hier erst mit rein dann
schmeckt es hat richtig um so mahlich
ich finde es passt ganz gut denn das
untere also der untere weise teil ist
dann schön süß und der obere teil eben
säuerlich deswegen gebe ich hier oben
auch gleich nur einen esslöffel zucker
mit rein
aber wenn euch das dauer ist könnte er
mal abschmecken könnte auch gerne
gebissen zugang
ich finde es passt alles gut und ich
finde unser passt ganz gut weil er hat
nach unten dieses süße und oben das
säuerliche und es sich dann dieser
kontrast und es passt es perfekt jetzt
gebe ich hier noch den esslöffel zucker
mit rein und dann wird es erstmal
püriert
und hier gebe ich jetzt auch noch mal
ein viertel teelöffel magazine mit dazu
das hilft dass ich ein bisschen gefunden
wird aber das wird jetzt nicht so fest
wie der untere teil ist bleibt er ein
bisschen flüssiger und ich finde dass
pastor eben super da hat man sich schon
wie so eine art kartell konfitüre
jetzt wird es auch auf gekocht und dann
muss man das auch wieder zwei minuten
lang kochen lassen
und diese mischung das jetzt hier
erstmal stehen als captain herz aus und
lasse so etwa 10 bis 15 minuten lang
abkühlen
je nachdem wie warm es halt auch in der
küche ist also darf nicht mehr zu heiß
sein dass direkt auf unser reserven das
panna cotta dass er es jetzt schon schön
fest und die hin wenn sie jetzt noch
laufen jetzt kann ich die schön mit dem
löffel einfach drüber gießen darauf
achten dass sie den rampen zu kleckern
und damit wird es später ganz eiskalt
genießen kann muss es noch mal in den
kühlschrank für mindestens eine stunde
besser sind sogar zwei dann ist es
richtig kalt und dann zeige ich euch
besser aussieht und respekt aus könnt
ihr nicht erfahren
so sehen jetzt die fed indes es aus als
sie sehen eigentlich genauso aus wie
vorher sind jetzt schön kalt und sie
sind jetzt auch fertig ich werde es
nicht probleme ich weiß wie es schmeckt
es schmeckt wirklich sehr lecker unten
die süße schicht oben diese säuerlich
fruchtig geschichte ich finde es passt
einfach perfekt zusammen
wer das jetzt transportieren wollte zum
beispiel auf eine feier würde ich
empfehlen das ganze dann auch wirklich
zu verschließen also diese weg geht
haben wir immer diesen gummiring
mitarbeiter sind also einmachgläser und
dann kann man das eben rechts und links
mit diesen clips verschließen kann man
es auch gut transportieren
wenn ich jetzt selber in den kühlschrank
stellen dann mache ich das einfach so
mit dem deckel ganz ohne gummiring
braucht man dann eben nicht
und ja ich finde es schon sehr hübsches
des ace der leckeres dessert vor allem
sehr erfrischend und wenn ihr das
nachmachen wird können wir einfach auch
zu lesen ist wir gehen da habe ich
nochmal die genauen zutaten angaben und
die zubereitung und ich würde mich
freuen wenn es nach macht und wir sehen
uns dann wieder beim nächsten mal
bis dann
und jetzt kann ich mithilfe von diesem
aus für behälter da als motiv im ausguss
trichter kann ich das ganz einfach ihr
auffüllen abgesagt die heißes ding aus
ausguss einfüllen und ich nehme jetzt
hier acht zu kleine gläschen das kleine
weckgläser mit deckel und ich finde ja
sogar praktisch essen sehen sie super
hübsch aus und die haben halt 140
milliliter auf füllmenge ein füllmenge